you're in Movie Makers you paid to be
movement makers that's a group
environment with everybody and then we
have this opportunity that comes up we
took four people and we're doing what I
want if you had your group there were
people who want to do one-on-one and
then I get to see you coach and there's
no prep because the prep is your years
of experience I don't know what you're
going to ask me coming in here right
that's the prep if you came and asked me
by Edmonton or something I have no
answer you're asking me things that I
should have an answer to and so it makes
them feel great it's usually more fun to
make because you're actually talking to
somebody instead of just talking to the
camera and it helps showcase the caveat
is you actually have to be a good coach
or if you suck at coaching that's going
to be a problem yeah hopefully you're
great you show off how great you are
that also is great conversion for your
landing page instead of just
testimonials here's been in action and
we can see you do what you do so it's a
conversion tool as well
thank you
we got bed in the house Ben's part of
movement makers we're sitting down for
one-on-one I'm excited about it yeah I'm
really excited about it I um I guess to
give you a bit of background site belt a
insurance and investment Agency for the
last 15 years got heavy into personal
development Lots into mindset
manifestation performance stuff and
throughout all of that I always knew
that I wanted to do speaking and
seminars and events and then just over
the last 18 months or so I've started
doing that so now it's figuring out how
do I start growing that brand I've got
several things that I've started doing
and I want to know how to elevate
quicker faster okay and everything so
what are we selling you as a speaker so
I do I've done two live Seminars the
seminars is kind of the dream I'd love
to do them all over the world that's
what I want to do most so my next one's
in September
and what's the seminar about uh this
last one I just did one on the weekend
called Vibe higher so it was a lot
around the conscious mind subconscious
mind your beliefs and then a lot of Law
of Attraction manifestation stuff so
creating life how you want okay that's
my big thing and who do we target it's
been a lot through my own natural
Network which is a lot of people that
are like entrepreneur type sales people
that stuff yeah okay and then are you do
you have something else that you're
selling yeah so I do coaching now I just
started a monthly membership just
released on the weekend where I do once
a month call so that just came out I've
got a small uh seven dollar like uh low
ticket course I got a 97 course so I
have a few things that have started I
just haven't had traction with
necessarily any of those yeah I want to
get beyond my own natural Network yeah I
got it okay cool and
you're making content where like where
are we at with content right now yeah a
produced contact I run a podcast for two
years
um I wasn't really using YouTube I was
just uploading it with only intent and
then just even in the last couple weeks
I learned through movement makers I've
tweaked some stuff on that so I want to
start YouTube as my main platform now
and then I happen to load apple on
Spotify where I did it the other way
before is the podcast is just you
talking or guests or both interviews
yeah both interviews and solo episodes
yeah what's the ratio uh right now I do
one to one okay it's not bad yeah once a
week
what's our timeline like are we do we
have to hit certain metrics in certain
timelines are we I don't have to no okay
but I'd like to you know God okay but
we're not like rushed like no I need to
get this by no okay perfect it just
allows it allows for more creative
things if you have a longer timeline
there's like I need to get this specific
media by next week kind of thing that's
right yeah got it we could take these
businesses in different directions like
if the goal is is speaking the key thing
is getting to know the people who are
hosting these events who are the people
putting it on and build a relationship
with them the easiest way to do that is
the biz Dev show so you have them on
your show you already have a podcast
it's great I don't know how you're
selecting the guests that come on your
show but now it's with an intent to I
want to get speaking gigs
from this person or their Network like
are you already thinking about that or
how have you picked I mean the reason I
started the podcast was to have a big
personal development brand podcast and
so my concern in that is that a lot of
the people I get on now are speakers
authors you know coaches that stuff
which I understand I can't Market to
them because they're in the same game
but not to dilute the podcast if that
makes sense so you have two choices
there one you start a different show
geared just towards this or two you find
an angle that it feels right in your
heart yeah to have them on yeah so if
you're looking who's putting on events
for entrepreneurs you can go research
all the events for entrepreneurs uh or
even like I don't know if you go into
sales or if you go into MLM yeah great
so all of those conferences or people
who are selling Insurance like all of
these things they're like
pseudo-entrepreneurs insurance people
are yeah you're kind of an unsure but
yeah not way less risk yeah right yeah
real estate same thing you're an
entrepreneur but there's like a support
system around it so there's lots of
events happening around those things
yeah
you find lots of all the events you find
Melissa who's organizing them you invite
them on your show to be a guest they
care about personal development yeah
otherwise you wouldn't be putting all
these events true yeah why put them
event for entrepreneur or is there real
estate professionals or MLM industry or
whatever yeah they care about this stuff
do you personally connect with them
enough that it feels right in your heart
to have them on the show you can make a
judgment call yeah whether it's a fit
for the main show or you start a
different show around it yeah but that's
gonna be your fastest path to get
speaking gigs right talk to the people
who are hosting the events yeah other
speakers and authors
not that they see you as competition
yeah but they're they're probably going
to take the deals that they like to buy
for sure you know and they may not
remember you or past like they have lots
of entrepreneur friends and speaker
friends that you may not be the first
person that they call yeah if they want
to turn it down that's right yeah right
so it's not that it's not possible it's
just a much longer road yeah so if you
want to be strategic and get we want to
get deals for our speaking gig like
that's the fastest way to do it yeah and
it's not that difficult to execute yeah
yeah and I guess doing it on YouTube's
easy too I was thinking more from the
podcast platform where it's only one
station but YouTube's easy to have the
different
series saw
yeah you filmed on the same channel yeah
I mean it could be Zoom or you can go
see them yeah and how much the
relationship means to you yeah right
like you came here from Remington that's
right so it's better to see them in
person yeah
that really helps fill the relationship
but you don't have to it may not be
worth you know it's a juice worth the
squeeze yeah to go off and do it just if
you ran the numbers if you were to run
uh that kind of show once a week in the
next year now you're meeting 52 people
who are hosting different events for
entrepreneurs
you're gonna get hired yeah
it's a great point you have to like suck
to not get high yeah yeah yeah then when
you're doing the interview
it's important for them to know that
you're a speaker as well so you're not
just the
the Larry King person asking questions
but you are
a speaker yourself so to start off the
interview you're talking about then when
the sh they're they're things that
they're they're either their story or
the event that's coming up but then
in the middle you talk about what you do
so oh that's amazing uh Henry I'm I'm a
what would you call yourself a mindset
coach yeah sure yeah mind-7 performance
yeah so I'm a mindset speaker and I I
speak at events and stages and one of
the things that I found is
what do you think about that now we've
positioned that you are a speaker yeah
you're not just a podcast host that's
right yeah right yeah we want all of our
guests to know that you're a speaker
yeah and then afterwards uh once the
show is done you can follow up now
they're on your list now for sure who
you are yeah you say if you need a
speaker for
this one or the good thing is these are
these are event organizers they'll do
another one yeah and another one another
one yeah right they might run five
events a year yeah you might not be a
fit for this one you can be fit for the
next one yeah
do you find linkedin's the best platform
for stuff like that
finding those people I mean to even
reach out to to begin with uh you need
to find the events find the events and
then yeah and then usually it's pretty
easy to find out who the person is okay
who's running it okay
so LinkedIn could work I'd probably just
do a Google search makes sense yeah find
the events find out who's organizing it
reach out these people who are running
the events
always get hit up can I be a speaker can
anybody speaking they don't want to talk
to another
up-and-coming speaker but hey I'd love
to have you come on and promote your
show and talk about what you're doing
everybody wants promotion so it's a lot
easier for people even if you had I mean
you already have an existing show but
even if you started from scratch and had
nothing and you're starting a brand new
show people will still come on
to do the interview because they want
content make sure one exposure yeah so
that's an easy like step one in the next
12 months that's the number one business
generator for you people who want to
grow whatever whatever program you want
to grow your speaking Yeah that you
bring on you want to grow your coaching
then same thing yeah bring on the
entrepreneur or the entrepreneurs oh I
guess still like again all of those
people if you search your backwards
Insurance yeah so many people like
insurance sales yeah
they need you man yeah I mean I have to
tell you that and how many Insurance
professionals are there in North America
I I don't know but a lot like a crap ton
yeah
and it could be helping the individual
uh the individual insurance wrapped or
could be the the office buying it for
yeah yeah
if that was your background yeah that's
my background yeah yeah is there like
did you win any awards or did you have
any yeah I mean we've run a good team
for sure
is that interesting to you to coach and
train I mean I do it in my main business
already yeah so it's part of what I do
what I'd like to do is get outside of
that where it's because my goal is to do
seminars for the public all over the
world
so I guess to answer that not as much I
mean I would speak probably at a
conference but I don't know if I want to
go train in Insurance offices so here's
the thing if you want to get paid
uh being on other people's stages and
doing coaching is the fastest way to get
paid writing your own events
is a longer term project or they just
won't be as big right and you're running
on my break even or a small loss that's
right right so that's more like what do
you yeah where what are we trying to
create because if you you can create a
speaking tour
and go to 50 cities or 20 cities or
whatever you want yeah but you'll
probably lose money doing it yeah so how
important is the yeah you know you could
I don't want to start with that no
okay so you have to be profitable along
the way yeah right yeah now it's just
thinking okay that's what you want to do
what are the steps to get there right so
for example if you started
if insurance is the easiest place for
you because you've already built a team
you've already done the sales you're
going to know what you're doing you
already know the language you know all
of it
if you started
picking off say you want to hit 20
cities and you pick the 20 biggest
cities in the U.S which you make more
way more money in the US than in Canada
and you find Insurance offices to go
work with and get paid to work with them
then when you start to do your tour it's
easy because you already have 20 cities
totally you have a you have a connection
network everybody around that they'll
show up and they can bring friends who
will show up and then you still may not
make a ton of money doing your own tour
but you won't lose money yeah the tour
yeah and then you get the vibe of doing
a tour and yeah it's building it
following too and then go back next year
like you can that could be a path to get
you there if you don't want to lose a
whole bunch of money on a tour yeah I
like that idea I think I was thinking
probably too small and too local which I
didn't really want to do but I mean
traveling to the states to go do a
a gig for an insurance company would be
cool and maybe Zoom training right to
start right but then you you do a tour
yeah and we did a 90-day tour 23 cities
yeah from Toronto to San Diego and back
yeah and mostly in different hotels
Conference Centers around the country
yeah it was it was a crazy long drive it
was a amazing experience yeah you know
like I did it because I was I wanted to
break the fear of getting on stage every
time and then I wanted to break the fear
of uh going off script so I had to
memorize presentation that I a third of
the way through I just cut it and just
went with whatever whatever float it's a
lot scarier cool yeah you know 100
people are sitting there and you don't
have a plan clearly yeah and the last
third I broke my neck and we continued
the tour with a broken neck no way so I
learned different things at different
stages like that tour that was 2019 and
it's still something I think back on is
like for sure that was a wild adventure
yeah you don't have to do 90 days yeah
and that many cities yeah but you could
start planning that to say Okay I want
to hit New York I want to hit like what
even if it's all east coast and you
don't want to hop on planes or whatever
you could do New York and Boston and
yeah Philadelphia and Chicago if you
wanted to like you could drive there
yeah you know maybe fly to one and then
drive across yeah so how do you start
getting clients at an insurance
uh company in those four states yeah so
you're planting seeds for your tour yeah
yeah I like that yeah I think probably
like you said too even real estate too
same idea
getting to some of those
the easy part about that is there it's
already all organized yeah finding
entrepreneurs is harder right
but finding
uh Insurance offices and all like they
all have websites you can see like who's
who would be the person who hired you
all right that's a good question we've
always run independently so I don't
actually know but
probably the agency owner I would
imagine who's the agency owner yeah
even if they're great at it they like
the best are still looking for outside
for sure people that come in and get
perspective that's right they listen
differently
yeah and so it's just a matter of
Outreach yeah cool if you're willing to
do it yeah
and then you you whatever you can the
best part of that is like it's it's
ongoing training it's not just you come
in once and then that's it
they need they need ongoing support and
the current team member who've already
heard you like they need leveling up and
then there's so much turnover that new
people are coming in that they didn't
even see you yet and so that becomes
part of the training as well so you
create an annual program
with each of these companies depending
on how many
people are at the hell like how many
people are at your office
uh probably a hundred and you change
them all at once like group uh we do a
lot of that group yeah not necessarily
all 100 at once be smaller classes in
person around Zoom both okay yeah so
that's some credibility like you've
already done it you've yeah office of
100 people yeah not just yeah I've
spoken in large groups already now not
just spoken two large groups like you
run a large yes yeah yeah so there's
credibility in the insurance business
yeah you're not some guy who's got like
two people underneath it yeah and are
just kind of figuring stuff out that's
right yeah otherwise why would they talk
to you yeah you've already built it to
100 person plus yeah I've done the live
training and zoom train so
anybody who's at a hundred uh or less
some of the 50 people once doubled this
year how do they do that each show yeah
make sense you can train them yeah and
you can get paid if you're training 50
people at a time
here do you make a lot more that if
you're training too yeah for sure the
owner has more money it has a budget you
have 50 people you've got a budget to
start yeah people for sure if you have
two you're like you're strapped and
you know barely hanging on
yeah
like it's a lot of times the
there's so many Consulting businesses or
coaching businesses yeah you can get a
couple hundred thousand revenue and
and be good and that starts to pay for
team and building the brand and
everything but it's it's harder to scale
right because it's still just your time
for money yeah it's good money yeah your
time but it's still just money for time
yeah but it gives the cushion to be able
to then go invest in all the other
things that you can do to hire a team to
help build everything else up yeah and
that's I guess that's kind of The Next
Step too is that so even the seminars I
have been doing a couple online courses
is just how do I start bringing more non
for my network traffic to that is I
guess the other part of it right so but
I know you talked about that's a longer
game on YouTube and stuff like that too
so
so if you have three options like the
biz Dev show relationships speaking is a
relationship thing
so that should be a Biz Dev show yeah if
you're looking at even the
the coaching part could still be part of
the biz Dev show where you're you're
bringing on you find an Office in Boston
and you find that an owner who's got 50
people on this team and you invite him
onto your show and even if it's just the
insurance show and you and this is a
different show than your podcast and
just you have him on he tells a story
and then you say yeah oh and what I I
mean I train this too I've got a my own
company we've got 100 people on the team
here's one of the things that I found in
working with people and now I train
others on it too what do you see so now
like you're an expert you're not just
asking the questions I know that you
have a hundred people on your team
like oh he's got a hundred people on his
team like why is he interviewing me I
should be hiring him right and then that
leads to a sales opportunity no not
everybody's gonna take you up on it but
uh if you did it again a show a week
with
people who run 50 people Insurance don't
raise yeah you'll get sales yeah and you
don't need that many how many clients
that have 50 agents could you have at a
time on your roster while running your
own agency while like you can't have
that many five
yeah so it's not that far a path to be
able to go get that Revenue coming in
yeah uh so that's the fastest way if you
have budget then adds
for speaking or for more for the uh no
speaking is harder yeah I would think
yeah speak his relationships right
speaking is a business death show yeah
build a relationship with all of them
see them in person if you can yeah again
it depends on what depends on what kind
of budget you're working with right like
if you said I'm pretty good I don't I I
you know I can invest in a crew and I
can invest in flying out to people
because I know it's going to pay off in
a three to five year window right cool
yeah do that yeah if you need to
bootstrap it like if you can afford it
then you would do something like this
yeah you know you fly to the person's
City yeah hire a local film crew yeah
and they set up
three cameras and a couple lights and
yeah you're good but that's gonna cost
you yeah each time you do it is the
relationship worth yeah five thousand
dollars or whatever to go meet the
person yeah plus your time yeah like you
get one Speaking gig it's definitely
worth it yeah but like how many of those
are you willing to kind of out for sure
right this is just uh if you have the
that's a fast way to do it yeah if you
have the budget to do it if not then you
don't over Zoom you'll still build a
relationship yeah or you or you judgment
call it it's worth it to go for this one
but not worth it to go for this one
right that kind of thing and then if
you're in the city you can also see if
there's anybody else in the network that
you can meet connect with right like I'm
going to Austin speaking of Austin this
week and okay who's who do I know was in
Austin
and meeting up and getting
recommendations and hanging out and some
people have only dm'd on Instagram some
people we've had Zoom calls some people
I've met before but those all lead to
other relationships other ideas it's
just a relationship game the speaker
side is a pretty small
Circle and it's harder to Target them
with ads yeah that makes sense for sure
but your coaching you could definitely
do ads if you wanted to spend and
courses and courses yeah you can for
sure do that yeah are the courses ready
to go yeah I have a I have like a small
seven day meditation that's really more
designed to be kind of like a lead
magnet but then a 97 one and what's the
97 5 module on that's called an Oru yeah
it might say yeah so it's like Vision
beliefs habits it's hard to make money
off of a 97 course if you're writing ads
okay the goal would probably be to
use the 97 program as you're like trying
to cost recover yeah and sell the
coaching okay what is coaching class two
grand a month yeah yeah it's a good
starting point yeah
um so that's the goal is like sell an
annual on the coaching okay you start by
selling 12 months yeah if that doesn't
work then you can come back
down yeah but the goal is an annual deal
okay just like when you sell insurance
you're selling yeah how long is the deal
yeah
so most people default to like month at
a time yeah don't do that that's what
I've been doing yeah yeah and if that's
the worst case you can always come back
down to it but for them to get results
what are they going to do in one month
oh for sure yeah I agree like you just
tell them what to do because they don't
know this is the first time they're
having this conversation but for you
you've had this conversation many times
so you have to tell them just like a
good insurance agent will they need to
understand the client and then tell them
this is what you should do yeah
because for the the clients they don't
know what to do it's their first time so
they don't know what to do how are they
going to make the best decision yeah you
ask questions and you get informed about
them then you tell them what they do
yeah so uh default the 12 months
default to up front 24 000 a year to
work with me
and here's what you get if and it's a
call every two weeks weekly is what I do
right now a call once a week yeah
for how long 45 minutes
that's not bad still probably call it 30
hours a week in my insurance agency yeah
and then wanting to grow all this other
stuff
and the mental calculation of what you
need to do to be able to leave the
insurance agency or dramatically cut
down to one day a week instead of 30
hours a week or whatever it is right
coaching is going to be your fastest way
to get there
in the insurance industry right so it's
like how much of that is a priority for
you
coaching or getting out of the insurance
business
it's not like a massive priority I got
to get out of it but I'm excited about
being able to point to eventually get to
the seminars all over the world
so do I need to leave insurance tomorrow
no I mean I can and these so you keep
you're excited about the seminars this
is great I am yeah and I love it so
they're your seminars yes and you
already have a vision for like what
you're going to be teaching the seminars
yeah yeah
I've done two of them so far yeah just
in limited yeah yeah and they've been
good they just you know takes time to
grow that's all
so a lot of that is building networks on
the ground in those cities yeah and you
come back yeah so I don't know how much
do you want to spend time on the road I
think if my family can come it doesn't
matter if I can bring my wife and kids
then it's fine okay so you're gonna like
rent a Winnebago or whatever and just go
I mean we'd probably do maybe that's an
exaggeration we wouldn't do exactly that
but like how long do you want to spend
on the road right now well I don't know
what's division where do you want to
what do you want to create I mean
eventually it'd be great to go like we
go to Europe for three months and I've
got a tour over there and then we're
living in Europe for three months
and then come back to Edmonton or or
spend yeah okay so like three months of
the year you want to be somewhere else
could be like that yeah and then I'll
probably once a month I'll go do
something myself too your own seminar
yeah exactly yeah yeah in North America
easy to get to like who who is the
organization that can help like speed
track that for you that you're not going
to go back to right or do you want to go
to Europe every year hit the same spots
I don't know you probably want to get
something else yeah even if you stick to
insurance for now
who are the major players that now
you're not talking to the individual
offices but the big conventions
not even the conventions but like the
companies yeah who can send you in you
know Mutual Liberty is going to send you
into yeah their offices around North
America yeah I'll have to look that up I
mean for the states but it'd be easy to
figure out who it is across Europe might
be more difficult in different countries
totally and I think that's more what's
the Brand's big enough like Bob Proctor
style that he could go anywhere and do
you know so but not necessarily right
like yes and like the way that Bob
Proctor does it and a lot of these guys
is because they built the brand up so
much they can go anywhere that's what I
mean yeah but you can get there a lot
faster just with a strategic
relationship and the biz Dev show is
still the like fast way to get you there
if you want to do your own thing as
opposed to like you're you're happy to
speak in other people's stages but it's
like the dream keeps coming back to yeah
I want to run my own stuffers and
Keynotes yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
excited by that I love it yeah so who
would hire you to be in multiple cities
yeah probably big insurance agencies I
guess
if they had you know they could bring
together all the State offices or
whatever and those are worth I mean
salespeople anyone that's commission
based basically the stuff that I teach
works well for for sure yes and
especially since you've had so much
success in the insurance business that's
the easiest one to be able to go off
that makes sense and create yeah it's
funny I never even considered it because
I was like I've already done that I
don't want to but it does make sense to
be able to teach in that way yeah
this summer this winter yeah we want to
get out of the Edmonton winter yeah and
hit up Florida and Texas and yeah
whatever Atlanta and just like go down
that air
side of things you could yeah you just
need the company who's going to hire you
to go
run all those events right okay that
could be this winter yeah this fall
whatever yeah
and just get those people on your show
yeah the thing is like who wants to talk
to an insurance VP
yeah nobody nobody
right I think the easiest guest of all
time yeah you're not trying to get the
rock on your show yeah no that makes
sense for sure that's what you can lose
LinkedIn like who would be the company
for you who would who
potentially hire a trainer for you to
come and watch
it just because we're all independent
it'd have to be the individual like
agency owners for us the automotive
insurance companies
here in Canada not the ones we deal with
because they don't have sales forces
they're just based on Independent
brokers
so but like Sun Life in Canada you know
it could be a company like that yeah
yeah that would bring together maybe a
sales training for various offices
yeah somewhere the captive insurance
companies would be like that
great
so
Sun Life who will be the person at Sun
Life for the department at Sun Life
and that's a good question
somebody in charge of sales I would say
something like that yeah yeah yeah and
so it was like that's when you go to
LinkedIn you're the company you know the
the job titles right you see everybody
who shows up hey you want to come on my
show
okay I started a new podcast about
success in the insurance Market cool I
have a I have an agency out in Edmonton
we've got 100 people and trying to share
some stories about insurance
great yeah and I think I would probably
do it I could do insurance real estate
mortgage broker or something like that
even
sure yeah if it's like it's still all
boring right like yeah these guys are
never asked about anything yeah like you
want to interview me yeah
so it's an easy yes I guess that'd be a
great channel for itself too yeah if
that doesn't fit within your your yeah
right now yeah yeah but even if it went
to there too I now thinking about it
it's just like those insurance sales
people real estate mortgages all that
stuff
as it grew go to there for advice and
everything too which ended up being
great prospects for all the other stuff
yeah yeah I've built the list it's still
you're not you're not teaching stuff
that you don't believe it
it's just a part of what you do yeah and
you're picking a couple of verticals but
yeah it's still all of your methodology
yeah and then so that's the quickest
path to revenue so then growing
more the personal brand side so I have
this community I just started once a
month call
things like that growing the YouTube I
mean as we go through the program and
we'll learn more about it but uh yeah
that kind of stuff so what else Beyond
The Biz Dev show so whatever you want to
sell show me the process of you doing it
so what do we want to sell we want to
sell our coaching Services we want to
sell our monthly uh is it a group yeah
okay our group but coaches 101 coaches
one-on-one 101 coaching our group our 97
program Yeah in our speaking yes
anything else we want to sell besides
the tours and that you're really excited
by yeah yeah no okay so those four
things so those become content series on
the channel
so show me you doing the thing what I
mean by that is if you want to be
selling coaching Services I need to see
you coach you talking to the camera
about how to use the Law of Attraction
doesn't mean that you're a good coach
you know Wayne Gretzky could be a great
hockey player was a great coach I don't
know is he good coach I don't know I
don't know coaching Canada oh yeah I
don't know if there's any again it helps
with the Oilers for sure so okay so but
like a lot of the best players actually
suck at coaching that's right yeah it
could be great that you've had the
success but it doesn't mean you can
teach me yeah so show me you coaching
okay so we're actually doing right now
like I'm coaching yeah so you just flip
it yeah so you take people who are
either in the program
already and go deeper with them uh or or
they're part of your group coaching
actually even how do we do this you're
in movement makers you paid to be a
movie makers that's a that's a group
environment with everybody and then we
have this opportunity that comes up we
took four people and we're doing
one-on-ones if you had your group there
were people who want to do one-on-ones
yeah
and then I get to see you coaching right
and there's no prep right because the
prep is your years of experience yeah
yeah I don't know what you're gonna ask
me coming in here right yeah that's the
prep if you came in ask me about
Edmonton or something I have no idea
yeah yeah if you ask me things that I
should have an answer to yeah and so it
makes them feel great yeah it's usually
more fun to make because you're actually
talking to somebody instead of just
talking to yeah a camera yeah yeah and
it helps showcase the caveat is you
actually have to be a good coach for her
if you suck at coaching yeah that's
going to be a problem yeah right you
know hopefully you're great and yeah you
share you show off how great you are
that also is great conversion for your
landing page so when it says you're you
know Ben landing page for coaching yeah
instead of just testimonials actually
you get to see you yeah right like
here's here's Ben in action right and we
can see you do what you do right so it's
a conversion tool as well cool it's
great for your email list yeah so when
people sign up your email list they
download your seven dollar thing your
pre-thing or whatever yeah in the Autos
Honda sequence they can also see you
coaching people oh he's a coach right
and when people see themselves in the
person yeah that you're coaching that
like oh if he can help her maybe he can
help me for sure yeah right so it's
you're it's a it's sales pitch without
any sales it makes sense right so that's
an easy series to make okay um anybody
who's come through your program yeah the
97 yeah yeah you could offer the same
thing if you complete the course then do
this and do some homework or whatever
whatever is the requirement uh then I'd
love to have you on as a guest it may be
something you eventually charge for yeah
right yeah it could be paid it could be
and it's going to cost 5 thousand
dollars to sit down yeah Ben 101 right
yeah but we're talking about the course
so then as they come through it's like
okay yeah I completed the whatever
course yep here's where I'm trying to go
next oh he has a course right now we're
talking about it again without talking
about it right instead of just a sales
video get my course yeah right again
that video can go on the landing page
for your course same thing for the
seminar I came to the seminar yeah give
them a coaching yeah that's a little
harder because you got to do it like
that's in person well I could have them
on after right I got the list so yeah
easy enough to oh you have a seminar
great yeah exactly yeah just bring it up
like how do we start this video it's
like oh yeah you're part of them yeah
and what was the last oh speaking speak
is a little different yeah I mean that
one makes sense for the business show
biz Dev show that for sure and speaking
speak yeah so either local stages yeah
high schools like if you just take
content of you speaking libraries
whatever like any local see what's
happening local in Edmonton and say I'll
come and speak just to get footage of
you on stage right speaking right and
direct the camera
H I have a bunch of that and I have a
bunch of crappy iPhone video uh talks
from just like conventions we've done
yeah though so I need to chop those up
and put them up on so like direct the
camera however often you can like less
time editing are you editing or you have
Team editing or what's happening team
that is yeah great so then every day
you're speaking like that's just uh
right the more you speak the better you
get at speaking and it's another chance
for somebody to find your video like my
first International
speech I got paid for was in Kuala
Lumpur
in 2014 and that was the closing keynote
for their event
he's like I don't know I found you from
your YouTube videos I did no Outreach
but he saw me speak so we need more you
content speaking the the easiest content
to make is trying to Trail off of other
channels so who is the most relevant to
the things that you talk about probably
Proctor my Proctor yeah I like I like
his stuff I like Berkshire stuff too
performance stuff Brendan yeah so go to
their channels yeah see what's
performing yeah make your version of it
yeah have you done that not regularly
but a little bit yeah okay so that's a
series yeah and that's on the main
Channel you know that's your solo
podcast yeah unless you want to have a
different completely different Channel
but that like makes sense to have it as
part of your for sure the insurance
specific one might be its own little
brand but yeah you speaking direct the
camera
take all of Bob's most popular videos
Brendan those popular videos
turn them into my version so you if
you're gonna go to like Louise Hay or
Wayne Dyer or yeah you know just expand
the list a little bit yep see what their
videos are yeah Mel Robbins at mylett
you know whatever yeah and then
just take the title yeah and then you
you don't even need to see how they
spoke like you're gonna speak yeah but
you're trying to pick a winning title a
topic that resonates with your heart and
you have something to say it's not
forced I'm only doing this to try to
rank but like this actually is important
how many videos a week should I be doing
between everything
depends on your ambition
and timing
uh
if you're not consistent the first goal
is one a week if you're one a week the
next goal is three a week if you're
three week then daily okay YouTube a day
long form
if you're there then it then it becomes
a much more about
the quality the analytics the metrics
how we do and which series is working
how do we improve it right the coaching
series is underperforming but it's
generating sales for us do we keep it or
not like all those kinds of things so
that's really a commitment level yeah if
if you can say I can commit to two
two videos a week kind of thing then you
just split them up so I mean we do one
already because we release the podcast
whether it's a guest interview or the
solo I did just face the camera so I'm
already one a week no problem so then
getting to three would be the next step
I just batch them right like today I'm
yeah
you guys are all traveling in here and I
was doing I've been just sitting here
answering questions yeah and uh now we
have content for the month so same thing
with the speaking the direct-to-camer
videos in half a day you could have your
content for the month yeah that's
something to get good at what's the
what's the hold up on it organization
and just kind of like do it when I need
to you know need an episode for next
week make it happen rather than matching
it so okay it's just booking it is all
it is I mean yeah easy strategy putting
the calendar yeah
like it sometimes it's I need I don't
know what topics yeah to figure out so
you might need a little time in advance
but yeah but like but even researching
the other speakers I mean that's an easy
way to get there's eight videos right
there do that on the next break and have
50 video ideas yeah maybe like it's not
yeah super complicated yeah yeah and
this is batch in time like Tuesday's my
YouTube day okay film content cool so if
you did
if you took Tuesday morning and you
filmed
eight videos direct the camera and then
you did six uh coaching sessions or four
coaching sessions in the afternoon
it's got a lot of content for sure and
then length of YouTube ideal is 15
minutes
no idea is longer oh okay minimum 10. so
face to camera even longer
if you have if you have stuff to say
yeah that's the hard part is like yeah
running out of stuff to say yeah yeah
and we'll get to this too in Movie
Makers but if you're looking at thought
leadership videos yeah
uh 10 minute plus but no Max we've had
three hour videos a crush yeah but like
can you talk every week for three hours
yeah like this ammunition returns yeah
but it's powerful opinion
like how do you start a video
I'm not sure how to answer that I don't
know okay so the new way to serve it is
a powerful opinion what do you believe
about blank that other people don't
believe
so like pick a subject that you would
talk about
subconscious mind okay what do you
believe about the subconscious mind that
most people don't believe well I think
most people don't have any idea that you
can program it for whatever you want
okay that's the first sentence of your
video yeah uh but not I think right it
is yeah subconscious mind is running
virtually all your life not any donor
it's running all your life and you don't
even realize so like hey that's that's a
hedge we can address the Hedge later on
yeah but don't hedge in the opening okay
because in the opening that's what
people are paying attention to okay and
if you're heading they want to hold on
to the safe right so even if it's like a
five percent hedge yeah they're gonna
hear the Hedge and not the argument got
it so powerful opinion right okay this
your subconscious mind is running your
life perfect then the next sentence is
the context sentence like what does that
mean so hopefully you told me something
in the first sentence that makes me stop
because your job is to stop the
scrolling if you can get them for the
first one right they'll watch the video
right people go to YouTube to learn yeah
right not just for inspiration yeah but
you still have to stop scroll yeah so
you told me something that I don't what
what did he say I don't know if I
believe this or not but that should be
the reaction yeah if you tell me
something that I just agree with then
why am I watching you yeah that's great
second sentence is the context sentence
what did you just what did you just say
like tell me it in a different in a
different way in a deeper way yeah to
help make it understandable and the
first sentence is raise the stakes so if
I don't fix this what happens if I don't
recognize this thing that the
subconscious mind you just keep
repeating the same life over and over
yeah
so you're challenging the perspective
right so I came in thinking I have this
problem yeah you're telling me I've got
this problem yeah
right yeah like what did he just say now
I want to watch this video cool those
are the first three sentences yeah right
then you tell the story yeah your story
a client story change the name change it
gender whatever story in the news Canada
Trump like any story a story yeah story
you got lots of stories that connects to
subconscious yeah Minds obnoxious
training whatever theme is right yeah
and then you get to the advice what we
want to do is leave with the advice for
sure
but people won't listen to the advice if
you don't do the proper setup yeah
because who are you why am I why am I
learning this this is important I've
already heard that before yeah next yeah
right powerful opinion context sentence
race mistakes story yeah and then advice
question for you just pause for a sex
show is it more effective if I had no
that you have to choose between other
like is it better to have three 10
minute videos or one 30 minute video so
that week as an example
I would probably split it to the three
the three ten minutes yeah if you had
the pick okay I wouldn't go under the 10
though like you hit kind of a magic
number there like okay it was three five
minute videos or one fifteen minute
video I'll do this with 15. yeah because
five is hard to teach people and say you
did an hour one would you ever chop that
until like three 20 minute ones later
you would release or do what you would
just read no but what I would do is mash
it up
mash it up so if you've done enough of
these hour-long ones sure then you take
clips from different from this one yeah
five minutes from all of them and then
it's your tips for success for 23 years
okay yeah you're compiling all of these
into a longer video and I think I
remember watching one of the videos you
did the other day that all YouTube
should have the very first note should
be uh freebie the magnet in the
description the description yeah so
here's what you do so powerful opinion
contact centers raise the stake story
right alrighty we're already like five
minutes in on this video depends how
long you tell a story
then you go advice number one okay so
the whole point of this is just to get
them in the right mode to receive the
information now we teach them okay so
how do we solve that how do you fix your
subconscious mind tell me Ben right and
then okay number one you start with like
what's number one awareness perfect yeah
number one is awareness yeah and then
you tell the story about awareness you
tell me what awareness means just take
me deeper into awareness yeah after
awareness you can say and by the way
guys I have uh a free PDF on how to so
would you drop us in most videos every
video every video you'll drop the
freebie if you have one freebie you drop
the same freebie right if you have
multiple freebies you drop the most
relevant freebie understood so if you
had something around awareness that fits
really well there yeah if it is in
meditation if it's a meditation but then
you say
you finish with awareness yeah you did
that whole point they're saying you know
one of the best ways to increase your
awareness is to meditate yeah and I've
actually got a free guided meditation
review if you want to check it out no
gloss it's the first link in the
description yeah go click it and I'll
see you there yeah okay number two
and then you move on to the academic
advice third bit of advice right right
yeah I like that well it works okay yeah
that's right and and now if you're going
you go through the whole process yeah
powerful opinion context sentence raise
the Stag story advice number one lead
magnet advice number two advice number
three yeah that's 20 minute video yeah
and that all fits on a on a sticky note
yeah like in terms of a screen yeah yeah
100 write out your powerful opinion
nails if you screw up on the first one
yeah and are you feeling by yourself you
have somebody filming with you I filmed
myself okay just like from the camera
I'm like so nail it you might need to do
it three times just to get the energy
and the vibe watch for any hedging
language right might may almost all like
okay none of those contains we do that a
lot yeah for sure for 10 layers yeah
most aggressive American in the world
[Laughter]
because if that energy is missing it
doesn't matter how much great advice you
have people got it they've Left Right
gone yeah if you screw up in the middle
it doesn't really matter right just keep
going okay if you Scope in the first
three sentences do it again okay and if
that takes 10 takes cool do it again and
until you get the words yeah and the
energy right yeah yeah you're feeling it
you're feeling it so that people will
feel it yeah yeah that's an easy 20
minute video so power those three
sentences you can write down and then
for the advice it's just point form yeah
awareness that part I'm good and then
you talk to it yeah and story you just
put whatever Danny that's right all the
Danny store easy right yeah it's all a
sticky note they got four minutes to
make that yeah that's great questions
around kind of like funnel systems so I
which I haven't built yet so I've got
several things that could be freebie uh
so I have a I just did a 30-day
manifesting challenge PDF that I just
gave out of the seminar which I'm gonna
put in the YouTubes now for the relevant
ones I gotta ebook people could have
okay and then I created this seven
dollar meditation course
but right now that's the only thing that
shows up in my description so I need to
tweak that so three but then how many
sequence emails should each freebie have
and then the second part to the question
when someone subscribes should they Auto
go into the Weekly Newsletter or they
should be in a primary funnel until that
sequence is done so both so the easiest
way to do it is not to have different
sequences for different PDFs okay just
put them all in the same no matter where
they come from selling the same thing at
the end let's say the 97 course yeah but
like if you have four different free
bonuses yes
you just put them on the first email
you don't need four different sequences
for each one the same email sequence for
each one yeah yeah so but email number
one is you give them the bonus yeah but
they think they're getting one bonus
because of what they signed up for but
you just get them all four bonuses oh
give them all four in that same email so
it's easy for you instead of running
four different funnels they're all in
that first email interest I do it for
like we do a vault we do a PDF for every
video that people can download
afterwards yeah and it you get one time
access you get all of it every video
like it's like a thousands or something
in there a lot of free PDFs so if I had
meditation eBook PDF Etc yeah one email
even though you only subscribe for the
PDF give them everything at all yeah
here in the first email yep not the
second value email or anything like
because they don't know where they're
coming from if they sign up for the
meditation but then they get in the
second email
then it's a disconnect for them
okay so like here are some figure some
amazing thank you for joining here are
some amazing bonuses for you ebook
meditation challenge yeah whatever okay
then it's uh in in the marketing World
known as an indoctrination sequence yeah
yeah right getting people used to you so
that is taking what are the messages
what are the videos ideally that we can
link to where people get to know who you
are because they don't know you they
watch one video put their email in like
I don't know who this guy is that's
right so what are the best videos for
them to see so maybe there's one
Speaking video there's one coaching
video there's one around the course like
there's things about so I get to I get
to know you in more depth uh and those
are your best ones because everybody's
gonna get them right in the
autoresponder sequence right uh the
newsletter could be
what is it weekly what are you doing
yeah so it could be a highlight from
your videos whatever the best video is
whatever's happening in your world or
thought of the day or thought of the
week
um but using video there too because
like the more people hang out with you
the more they want to buy from you and
do stuff with you and video is like the
easiest way to go one to many yeah
people feel like they know me even
though like I have no idea like Evan how
you doing and how's Nina and how's like
yeah great who are you yeah yeah right
they've developed these relationships
and that's kind of what you want you
want you want people and ideal clients
to feel like they know you even though
you have no idea who they are yeah so
thinking about which videos could be
good fits and if you don't have them yet
make them on your next yeah recording
session so even an example when you say
the course I should have a YouTube
selling the course not selling but
explaining it no you have a YouTube
coaching session oh with some from
someone that went through the course
yeah completed the course okay here's
Susan she just completed my XYZ course
oh my God Ben that's such a great course
cool I had so much fun okay right yeah
and then that video goes on YouTube but
it also goes on the landing page for the
course and it goes in an email seek I
love it so like one video is yeah
multi-purpose we just had a lady that
went through Jim came to the seminar too
okay and she's her and her family
haven't been on vacation a decade and
she goes I wanted a vacation it's this
crazy long story I'm not gonna tell but
she legit manifested a five thousand
dollar vacation so I'll get her to oh
come on I'll coach her and tell her to
tell that story that's great that's an
amazing story yeah but then like how
then can you help her next what's the
next thing for sure she got that Daniel
what's yeah I have lots I got on board
without you she's in the insurance
business too so yeah that's the model so
between
those Series so we need to direct the
camera you we need uh that's gonna help
solar speaking we have a Biz Dev show
for the insurance agencies slash
people who are running events that yeah
go speak at so you start building those
connections just to pause for one sector
I think I remember one of the training
videos that show is totally irrelevant
you're not trying to grow a following on
that it's just more to connect with
those people yeah if it does yeah if
you're doing a show about insights into
the insurance industry who cares yeah
yeah I mean some people will still watch
it right and it's still probably the
ideal clients for your guest right but
the whole point is not even to build
your brain but just to build a
relationship yeah and give them content
right they have content now too it might
be the only interview they've ever done
yeah
and do you well I guess answers yes
because that's what you do YouTube
always over podcast
because the YouTube can just convert to
podcasts anyways yeah and you can now
list the show as a podcast on YouTube I
saw that yeah yeah I just did that for
others yeah you're already recording it
the thing with YouTube it's not just
like YouTube versus podcast a video
gives you so many more assets totally it
does now you have Tick Tock now you have
Instagram yeah sure you know all of it
yeah because you have the long form
video if you have Audio Only You can't
do any of that stuff yeah like audio
only on a YouTube short or an Instagram
reel socks yeah yeah for sure it does it
used to be like which one is better and
I would still default to YouTube anyway
but now it's just video and then
everything else that that video with
your Biz Dev show you could take the
transcript and turn it into an article
can you LinkedIn cool you could chat GPT
yeah the the video yeah and that becomes
an article for LinkedIn yeah it's like
all you have to do is create that long
form content at the top yeah and then it
could be broken down to yeah 100 pieces
of content from one interview how many
people do you need like va's and stuff
to do with that side because that's the
part that I've I've only done Instagram
and then now starting with YouTube Just
because I don't want to do all that
stuff
you need an editor okay video editor
video editor who can ideally do long
form and short form yeah and it might be
a full-time job depending how much
content if you're doing twice a week
yeah long form and then short form it's
still probably not a full-time job but
the short form they're just clipping
from the log form anyway exactly yeah
you have to go through find the clips
that you like yeah change the sizing
yeah if you're going daily content or
you're doing like four times a week then
you're probably at a full-time position
do you recommend va's primarily for that
yeah yeah
there's lots of people can do editing
okay
and then you need one person again
part-time person to post and they just
did a strategy they should be told what
to do so
post to Instagram take two clips a day
and post to Instagram and tag these
people right take this short and like
Tick Tock Instagram reels uh Facebook
reels and YouTube shorts can all be the
same piece of content yet
so then it's just somebody manually
going to each place and posting them
yeah there's some tools that can help
but they don't do all of them yeah right
like we use Agora pulse but it doesn't
do YouTube shorts right somebody needs
to go in and log in it's it's you're
gonna you're gonna rip your hair out
China for sure see that's like yeah the
most basic of basic work yeah that you
don't need to hire
like it could be your video editor but
you're paying a different rate like your
video editor
shouldn't be posting
to your Instagram yeah Danny's here like
filming all this stuff if I asked Danny
to eight times a day post to all my
social media
it's gonna throw me out the balcony it's
like I'm doing that work yeah right yeah
so you're probably looking at one
full-time person but split between two
people and if you have administrative
staff already working with you yeah then
that's you can give them
yeah work yeah they just need to know
exactly what to do yeah which is
relatively easy yeah
um and then the video editor needs to be
not best in class but needs to be able
to do the editing work yeah for where
you're at that's okay
it's not that complicated we have 52
people on the team but we're doing a
like we have a Russian Channel with a
million subscribers and we have a
Spanish show other members of the
rappers and we split test every video
we've done like 25 000 split tests on
our videos and we do a PDF for every
single video on our Channel like the
transcribe is how it is it's not
transcribed but it's a like a PDF
worksheet for every video okay so we're
crazy like don't you don't have to model
that yeah we just need to get you yeah
let's draw one screen you got some work
to do or do yeah I love it thanks right
appreciate it thank you to see me
coaching another entrepreneur one-on-one
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it
continue to believe
see you there